here we are just 13 days away from the
midterm elections and last night we had
major debates from three critical races
that will likely play a very big role in
November and moving forward in Michigan
Republican gubernatorial candidate Tudor
Dixon absolutely annihilated incumbent
Gretchen Whitmer on Covert lockdown
school closures and so much more now the
governor tried to lie her way through it
she claims schools were only shut down
three months uh not exactly the truth we
will tell you the truth as the night
unfolds and meanwhile in New York a
powerful performance by Republican
gubernatorial candidate Lee zeldin he
confronted the current governor Kathy
hokel on the stage violent crime wave
leaving hokel to wonder you know
mysteriously you know why do you care so
much about this issue of crime Governor
here's a hint people are dying now both
Tudor Dixon and Lee Selden will join us
Straight Ahead also Georgia Senate
candidate Herschel Walker will be here
but we begin tonight in the great state
of Pennsylvania the Commonwealth where
Dr Oz He will join us in a moment with
reaction to one of the most well I guess
you can say unusual debates in American
history now tonight it's official the
cover-up is over Democrats the media mob
the fetterman campaign they were all
lying to all of us John fetterman is not
mentally physically cognitively fit to
serve he should not be running for the
Senate and in a word what we saw last
night was painful hard to watch I'll
give my full analysis in a moment but
here's how fetterman started the entire
debate take a look at this you're
running for a seat that could decide the
balance of power in Washington what
qualifies you to be a U.S senator you
have 60 seconds
hi good night everybody
good night everybody that was the
beginning of the debate unfortunately it
went downhill from there take a look
he has specifically said you have not
paid your taxes and that you want to
raise taxes on Americans how do you
respond uh absolutely the odds rule of
course he's lying it was helping two
students 17 years ago to help them you
know buy their own homes they they
didn't pay the bills and it got her paid
and it's has never been an issue in in
any of the campaign before
it was all about non-profit has Leiden
Administration overspent and if so where
do you think spending should be cut you
have 60 Seconds
no here's what I think we have to fight
about inflation here right now that's
what we need to fight about inflation
you know right now because it's a tax
let's say you know he got is
from his own inlays from a dollar we all
have to make sure that everyone that
works is able to that's that's the most
American bargain that if you work
full-time you should be able to live in
dignity as well true there's the real
doctors that I believe and they all
believe that I'm ready to be served it's
about supporting and helping you know
young earners excuse me young
young uh
young you know students
it gets worse when confronted about his
blatant flip-flop on the issue of
fracking he's called for a moratorium on
fracking while fetterman's answer was uh
well I'm four fracking I'm against
fracking I'm for it take a look
I do want to clarify something you're
saying tonight that you support fracking
that you've always supported fracking
but there is that 2018 interview that
you said quote I don't support fracking
at all so how do you square the two
oh I I I do support fracking and
I don't I don't
I support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking
I support fracking and I don't and I do
I mean sad honestly obviously that is
not true John fetterman is a radical
Green New Deal uh socialist Democrat
he's never supported fracking uh this
late election year conversion until now
he even signed a pledge pictured right
there uh to ban all fracking and ban
Federal oil and gas leases now of course
there are a lot of dishonest Democratic
candidates who have you know election
year conversions sadly fetterman's
problems are far far worse now following
a debilitating stroke he is obviously
mentally impaired serious damage has
been caused here just listen to the
neurologist that was on news Nation
after the debate listen to this
from watching the debate I do think that
he has a type of aphasia specifically a
Broca's aphasia which essentially means
that there's been some type of insult or
damage to the part of the brain where
language is produced but also language
is understood do you get better
so it depends you know someone mentioned
therapy and therapy can be very very
helpful especially if you are doing it
every day and you're taking a lot of
time in your therapy essentially what we
know is that in the first three to six
months is where you see the most
Improvement there can be some
improvement over the next year but I
think he's about six months out now this
happened in May so I think if he was
doing therapy right after his stroke
this is probably where he's has improved
to the most
here's an important question six months
ago was John fetterman even able to
fully consent to this campaign naturally
the fetterman campaign they're now
blaming the debate host next star for
not doing enough to help mitigate
fetterman's mental disability now next
star rightly flatly rejected this
accusation in writing that they went to
extraordinary lengths to accommodate
every one of fetterman's Demands
including the use of a closed captioned
teleprompter and two prior rehearsals
now this is where it gets even more
interesting many Democrats around the
country they're mad they're complaining
that fetterman even dared to show up to
the debate at all they should have kept
it hidden according to a report in the
hill one Pennsylvania Democratic
operative stated quote fetterman's team
never should have agreed to this debate
a second Democratic operative concurred
you see what's happening here if we only
hit him in the basement like we did Joe
Biden in 2020 we at least would still
have a Fighting Chance our odds would be
be better they don't care that fetterman
has disqualifying physical limitations
here they don't care that he will be
unable to fulfill the most basic duties
of a U.S senator they don't care at all
about the amount of dangerous stress
that they're actually putting him under
putting him in a situation like last
night instead they're upset they're
Furious that the voters found out you
should have kept it hidden you should
not have told the voters you shouldn't
have allowed voters to see this now
they're angry that the truth was
revealed in fact for many months many on
the left and their complicit colleagues
in the media mob they worked hard to
conceal fetterman's real condition and
before last night most quote journalists
praise fetterman's speedy recovery and
few demanded to see his medical records
now few played his disjointed remarks on
the campaign Trail they hit it from all
of us no one in the Democratic party
said a word about his debilitating
mental impairments they all knew about
it but two weeks ago when one brain
Brave NBC reporter dared to report the
truth they attacked her viciously and
fetterman's wife called for the reporter
to be punished and her own NBC
colleagues like Savannah Guthrie were
attacking her that reporter is owed an
apology but she likely will never get
one fetterman's wife knew better that
her husband was unfit so did the rest of
fetterman's family and so did the media
mob and so did Joe Biden and so did Amy
Klobuchar so did everyone who attempted
to interact or campaign with John
fetterman they all knew and they were
all part of the big lie to keep this
from the people of Pennsylvania now that
the truth has been revealed some
Democrats and others in the media
they're finally stating the obvious
which we have known for a long time
which we are the one of the few shows to
have pointed out take a look
voters I think saw things that will
definitely change the state of this race
it's not his fault but lieutenant
governor fetterman struggled he's
struggling with the effects of his
stroke that he suffered in May
um and you know I said it's it's very
obvious that he is impaired his ability
to communicate is impaired he had
difficulty with every single one of his
responses I don't know if it was only in
communicating it may also have been in
his thought process because he seemed
confused I watched the debate last night
it was hard to watch frankly
all right let us be clear I don't wish
any ill will on John fetterman I want
him to make a full recovery I also
frankly really feel bad for him he's
been used by everybody in his own party
and all the people around him in order
to pick up a senate seat the Democratic
party is taking advantage of a person
that is obviously severely sick and
seriously disabled a low-functioning
individual he should be in recovery he
should be in rehab and all the while
they were not telling the people of
Pennsylvania the truth about his
condition so tonight Pennsylvania voters
they still don't know the extent of
fetterman's health problems because his
campaign is still refusing to release
his real medical records but if last
night as any indication it is pastime
for fetterman frankly to drop out of the
race for his own well-being hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else